i relapsed not proud of it
um but i am back on track kelly osbourne
is opening up about her sobriety
revealing she
recently relapsed after nearly four
years of being sober
this is something i've been working on
for a very long time
on monday the 36 year old tv personality
took to her instagram stories to let her
followers know what she's been going
through
this is a little hard for me to talk
about but i've always promised you that
i will always be honest with you about
where i'm at
and and what's going on in my
road to recovery um
i relapsed not proud of it
but i am back on track the former
fashion police star who now hosts the
kelly osbourne and
jeff beecher show podcast shared that
she would be opening up
even more on an upcoming episode though
she didn't specify if it would be her
own podcast i just want to let you know
that
i am sober today and i'm going to be
sober tomorrow
but i've learned it truly is just one
day at a time
and i've wanted to tell you guys the
truth
because i never ever want to lie to you
thank you so much for your support and
your love
of course this isn't the first time
kelly has talked about her sobriety
i don't know how i kept going i think
that's why i did so many drugs to be
honest
i numbed myself painkillers don't just
kill physical pain they numb your mental
pain too
in 2017 kelly opened up to e.t about her
battle with addiction
something her dad rocker ozzy osbourne
has struggled with as well
do you think that also seeing your dad
seeing
what addiction looks like i'm an addict
too
yeah you know what i'm saying i can't
say that i'm not in the program
i won't and i don't call myself sober
but oh you don't
no i want to make that very clear i just
don't do drugs
and i do other therapy i don't
go to the i'm not in the program right i
think it's disrespectful to claim that
you want when you're not
so that is very important to me to get
that across because it is unfair to
everybody who is in the program
and works it the way that they do
because it works for everyone
the former reality star who has had
several stints in rehab
which she documented in her 2017 memoir
there is no
secret appeared on the british talk show
lorraine in 2019
and opened up about her decision to get
sober in 2017.
you know i'm almost two years sober and
it's completely
changed my life i i didn't think that i
could
do anything if i if i wasn't drunk or
high
because i was scared of everything and i
let it get the better of me
and when it spoke with kelly in march
2020
right as the world was starting to
quarantine amid the coronavirus pandemic
she opened up about prioritizing a
healthy lifestyle
it's crazy that it took quarantine to
get me to start like
working out that last 10 pounds i want
to lose you know
so i've been so healthy every day i'm
like taking all my vitamins
juicing and just trying to stay positive
i think that
when you see somebody walking say hi